körpergewicht stadt kleider preise
tod im brot
und monster statt models
basta verpassen den werbeplakaten eine
neue aussage
basta ein wort gebildet von etfs und
werbung und basteln von two passt also
kaputtmachen auffliegen lassen
basta sind illegal unterwegs und deshalb
auch nicht als gruppe organisiert
angefangen hat die bewegung ende der
80er jahre verlassen war erst selber
werber und hat dann das magazin
adbusters gegründet
einer unserer techniken ist es die
original werbung der industrie zu nutzen
es ist wie beim judo wenn ein
riesenmonster auf dich zukommt packst du
es und wirft es mit einer schnellen
intelligenten bewegung auf die matte
wenn das funktioniert wendet sich die
ganze energie der milliardenschweren
kampagne plötzlich gegen die firma
selbst
die leuchtreklame von camel wirft
plötzlich eine existenzielle frage ob at
t das
sind impuls sich an der besucher ist das
ist doch ein wenig größer aber dann muss
er wird nachhaltigkeit zu erfinden sie
meistens nicht
nachhaltig eine botschaft im helm
verankern das möchte der preisgekrönte
werber pierce war mit seinen kampagnen
und dazu nutzte auch die mechanismen der
add basta
etwa den überraschungsmoment für amnesty
international stellte er plakate her die
folterszenen zeigen und zwar an dem ort
in der stadt wo das plakat hängt der
passende slogan nicht hier aber jetzt
das ziel kommt man ist wirklich dass wir
die nachhaltigkeit geschafft haben
seitenhalt dass alles vorbei ist das
situation und im moment nicht was haben
die werkstation weiß sofort was ich zu
tun habe nämlich amnesty international
unterstützen die organisation bekam ich
das weltweite echo in medien und blogs
enorm viel aufmerksamkeit
überraschungsmomente auch auf anderen
kanälen
er begrüßte die idee das ist richtig die
wohl die idee die drei damals die 3000
exekution umsetzung und zu wehren das
ist also eine richtig gute idee die
hinter einem aus dem alltagstrott uhse
die zeit oder showbusiness mauerwerk mit
guten ideen sie gewohnheiten sprengen
das tun etwas da auch
in berlin wo sie den porno darstellerin
und eine kollegin die kälte verpassen
oder in paris statt werbung plötzlich
kunstprojekt
dennoch anti-werbung kämpft genau gleich
wie werbung um die aufmerksamkeit des
publikums
vielleicht den radikalsten widerstand
gegen die flut von bildern und
kaufanreizen übt dieser adbusters er hat
die nase voll von werbung und lässt sie
ganz einfach verschwinden